it's much easier to be on the giving
side than the asking side or the
knitting side so as long as i can be
in the giving side in every aspect of my
life
i really try to you know to do
everything in my power
to actually be at that side and to
justify it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
this one is about
impact and a lot of impact meet bachelor
moshe
manager of pauline high tech activity at
bangkok
bachelor is the manager of polymer high
tech activity in the banking arm of bank
appointing for startups and high tech
companies
prior she served as the strategic
consultant to the chairman of bangkok
and beforehand bachelor was the ceo of
unistream
one of israel's most influential and
impactful ngos that narrows the
socio-economic gaps by empowering youth
and young adults from underprivileged
communities to establish startups and
integrate into the high-tech industry
welcome to my show how are you great how
are you
thank you for having me i am i'm so
grateful to have you here
we're gonna have a fantastic
conversation the truth is we already had
a fantastic conversation
and i'm and i'm extremely lucky because
i get to have two conversations now
where everybody's just going to get to
listen to one of them so
i am the winner of this whole situation
thank you for my time again
but the impact that you've had
a on people around you uh is
phenomenal i can't think of you know
many people have had this extraordinary
impact
and all the way from your work with
unistream and today your work with
pauline high tech and your work with
helping people find jobs
and i think that it all speaks to this
overarching idea that you shared with me
about making a greater impact and i'd
love to just
you know go back a little bit through
your story and
hear from you what what went down how
did you get to where you are today
and where you're headed where should i
start
at the beginning all the way to the
beginning okay so
i was born and raised to a really
dianist family
my father made a liar from the us and
uh it was really a part of you know my
education
thinking about israel and you know
creating an impact
and and when i was a teenager
i started doing a lot of the volunteer
work of course i was a part of the youth
movement
you know and um and when i
finished in my high school i i joined
the national service
and uh i was the head of a branch of uh
of neyakiva which is a one of the
largest youth movements
in israel and for the first time i was
in what's called the
ayahuasca i don't know how to translate
that
and but um i was a head of the branch
there and for the first time i met
you know a teenagers and and kids that
you know didn't have the best uh
starting point and had a lot of
challenges
in their lives in order to strive and in
order to be successful and
for me to meet them and to see people
that are coming from
you know a challenging socio-economic
situation
it gave a lot of insights of what kind
of person do i want to be
or do i only become in addition how
lucky am i
you know to come from a a strong family
that could you know guide me throughout
this very difficult life and and start
some sometimes really scary life and
they i i
decided to you know to dedicate a lot of
my time
in the future to try to make this place
better
and to try to give people that didn't
have the same opportunities
as i did big opportunities and new
opportunities
to become successful to go on the right
path
to have opportunities to choose their
future
so when i met my
amazing husband called chai actually was
a part of my national service
i met him there we decided when we
decided to get married we thought where
will be our first home and we heard
about this
phenomena called young communities of uh
families
that are going all over israel to the
periphery
the peripheral areas to build their
you know homes there and try to create
an impact from the inside
try to become a part of the community
improve the education system volunteer
work with the welfare department et
cetera et cetera
so we heard about aqua which
was at that time considered to be a
challenging place
they've been through an amazing path
because of a great leadership in the
town
but at that time it was the after uh the
second
[Music]
half and uh and
ever you know the uh moral of the
community was really really
uh down to earth right and and and many
strong families have left
the town to different locations and and
the situation became
even uh tougher than it was before so we
from you know from today to tomorrow
decided to move to aqua we're both from
the center of israel
and we find a an apartment there in some
really you know challenging neighborhood
let's call it that
and uh and started our we were very
young i was 22 years old and we started
our first you know
a journey there and and i
i met you know difficulties all around
me
people that really their starting point
is life
is really really really challenging
everything i knew before even in my
national service
service didn't even come close to the
situation we met
there and uh and the socio-economic
situation was really bad for
i would say even the majority um
of the residents in the town and it was
uh i was pretty desperate because i saw
so many amazing organizations
working working in aqua and trying to
create an impact and you know when
you're looking at the big picture
it doesn't really seem like something is
is moving around even though there are
so many good people that are trying to
to create a better future and a better
you know presence for this place uh when
i was uh
25 a few years after we moved to arco
i heard about an organization called
unistream
i never heard of them before and uh
i came to understand that they have an
entrepreneurship center
in acco actually like a street across
from my apartment
amazing and um and i i went for an
interview to
lead the center the entrepreneurship
center in akko
and when i first came into the center i
saw these teenagers you know like
like uh signing uh in their eyes
and talking about their startups and
their fundraising
and about their investment committee and
all of that and and
telling me what they're doing and i was
like oh my god there is like a
different thing going on here and i
i came to uh learn about the
organization it was already
uh about 11 years old and the idea was
that
uh instead of like telling you you know
become a leader
you know fulfill your dream let's give
you the the pathway
let's give you this tool in order to
change your economic situation
and become a part of the startup nation
for real so the methodology of this
organization
says that it will start early enough
with teenagers which is a very important
stage of their life because it's before
the army
it's before the university and it's a
soon enough in order to change you know
the way you finish high school
and so let's give you everything you
need
the network the knowledge the experience
in order to
do entrepreneurship to establish your
own startup company
and we'll walk you through this process
and eventually
first of all you'll understand that
there is a whole world out there that
you weren't familiar with
and in addition you'll know that you'll
know the people you'll know the
opportunities that you potentially have
in order to choose differently
or in order to have a different life
than you you know
this guy has written for you i don't
know how to translate that
but um i fell in love in the
organization so i was the head of the
center for one year i led
a few starters a few groups of teenagers
and a year after that i became a part of
the management it was a management team
it was a real small organization we
all all in all we were 20 people uh
and it was really cool
i had a lot of fun but i thought we
could do more than that
um three years after that i had a
like um a meeting with the chairman of
the organization his name is ronnie
taram
and i didn't really know him before i
saw him a few times we never talked
and uh it was a really good conversation
and i was like uh uh on my way out of
the organization because
i felt like i gave everything i could in
this you know scope
and you know i can't do anything more in
in my specific
position and i don't have word to grow
to
above me there is a ceo and that that's
it
and and finishing the conversation he
says
can you be the next leader of unistream
and i looked at him i was 29
i didn't really manage you know
something
meaningful in the past in the past i i
looked him in the eyes and said
of course of course i can and uh and
he's like
okay pretty much from now on you're the
newspaper of unistream
so even though it was a small
organization about five million shekels
of the budget
and the 20 employees about 500 teenagers
i felt i received the opportunity of my
life
and i decided that you know nothing will
stand in my way and i'll be the best
thing that ever happened to unistream
and
and i really try to even though i
thought that there is a lot of knowledge
and a lot of skills that i don't have
but you know i really wanted to to be
successful and create a big impact
and i think that you know there is if
there isn't
anything um stronger than will in hebrew
there is
the phrase end of our medicine and
it's really true so um really the day
after
starting changing the organization and
and pretty much
making making it bigger um
more like creating a larger impact and
when i mean
larger i i was talking about not only
location
and the number of participants i
understood that we
need to take it to the next step because
before that we were working only with
teenagers
and we weren't there for them for real
in the day after when they're
actually starting their life and that's
even more important than working with
teenagers because that's the first time
they're going out to this big world
this scary world and no one is you know
uh on their back taking care of them
so we started creating all kinds of
alumni program
and then training program to become a
part of a high-tech industry training
for
all kinds of position and placement
program in order to actually make sure
that our
alumni are integrated into the companies
and then
all kinds of programs to the communities
and the parents and
everything else and from you know for
like
in one year or two years this
organization became like a
multinational organization working in
about
100 locations in israel working in the
united states
uh more than four times the budget and
so many people involved we have we had
more than 5 000 people that
volunteered in unison everyone in the
ecosystem
in the high-tech ecosystem were a part
of unistream and we had this big huge
event
uh in khala talbot every year called the
entrepreneur of the year competition
uh and uh 3 000 people have came to this
a competition to see unison and it
really is unbelievable and you know it i
was really inspired by by
you know looking at this at the high
tech industry and the way that they
they like chose to be involved and to
contribute and to be a part of this
amazing journey
uh so about the year about a year before
i left you in a stream i came to the
conclusion that okay
you know you need to say goodbye when
you have the energy
like they want and not too late and
and when i looked around me i thought
that if i want to create even more
impact i need i need a space in my life
in the business industry
because it's like the missing part i'm
talking about entrepreneurship i'm
talking about business
but i have never been actually a part of
any kind of
of a business institution or a startup
only on the impact
yeah so only in the social impact aspect
and and i felt
like it's like some kind of a deficit
that i have and i need to overcome
and i was starting to talk with some
ceos of the big high-tech companies and
uh actually not many because i was
really really focused i wanted specific
companies
that i could look at and say they're not
only you know successful
they're doing some kind of an impactful
aspect they have some
some kind of impact of changing the
world i can give some examples but
anyway i was in this starting to talk
with all of those uh ceo
and then i had like a a pretty
unexpected meeting with obedience
which was the former uh a chairman of
bangkapoli
and he was like asking me even though i
never told him i'm
i'm about to leave or and thinking about
it he was
asking me you know what what are your
plans for the future
and i told them i i made a decision i
need to
move to the a business world i needed a
phrase in my life and i told him
you know i'm looking at this company and
this startup and this uh high tech
company etc and he's like okay you're
going to your comfort zone listen to me
you want to learn about business
really to learn about the business world
come to bangkok police
work with me so uh i was like oh my god
that the amazing amazing chairman of
anger pauline calls me you know
what do i know about banks nothing
actually
and but he really i don't know why he
really believed in me and he really
wanted me to come
so i thought about it for a day even
though i said a week
and i waited another day so i wouldn't
look too enthusiastic about it
and then i i texted him okay boss
when do we start so um seven
months after that because i had to give
a long notice for unispring
seven months after that a year and a
half uh
a year and a half ago i started working
with him
as a as the strategic consultant for the
chairman of bank of pali
and for the first time was i was sitting
you know in all of the board meeting
and with you know all kind of strategic
conversation and big projects and big
things that are influencing not only
the bank but the whole economic uh
you know you could say the whole
economic industry of israel because
this this organization is really large
and and manages
so much to many of the public and there
are so many important decisions
and and responsibility that we we have
to take into consideration
uh in everything that we do and and i
have to say that from day one i was
trying to find a place of myself to
continue the social impact and not only
the business
journey that i decided uh to take
because
you know eventually when i wake up in
the morning this is what i'm looking for
you know how did i make this world
better and it's not like you know uh
how do i say that it's not like a
gimmick or something like that
it's really what makes me you know smile
in the mornings
uh and so when i started uh at bangkok
pauline
pretty quickly i joined pauline baquilla
which is the foundation of bangkok
that is responsible for all the social
activism of the bank which actually does
so many amazing things you know but
being in the side that
actually have the resources is really
different it's really different than
being in the site that always asks for
the resources
i can't say i can't say which side is
better because
there is something that there is you
know a meaning for you actually doing
the things and not only
you know um deploying the money to other
organizations to do
but i i i think that we and bank of
polling really try not to be only
you know the money givers but actually
involving the organization
empowering them guiding them you know
helping them grow
in so many ways doing uh initiating a
lot of projects of our own
and but still was a journey it wasn't
easy for me this
past year and and uh a year after that
first of all unfortunately has passed
away
uh of course it was very sudden and he
was
an amazing person and i am so privileged
to have this you know 10 months
of working with him i learned so much
mainly
and not only about business because he
promised to to teach me that
but about you know being a person that
he's so high level person you know you
one of the you know most wanted
positions
in the in the market probably but he was
really really really a modest person
and um i'm always saying that you know i
learned a nava
from a dead who
we went he was always thinking about the
people thinking about the
you know the small person that's in the
room asking him how he felt and how can
he help him
et etc and for me it was amazing looking
up to him and learning from that okay so
the last thing that we talked about was
this understanding of impact joining a
apolem and working with with your
phenomenal
with your phenomenal partner and
then transitioning now to a different
opportunity that is
making a huge impact in the ecosystem
and
and that's part of your bigger
trajectory as well
yeah so uh actually when uh odette was
sick
and uh i understood that you know soon
he will be leaving the bank
unfortunately
no one thought it will be so fast i
started thinking about my next step
and i thought i want to you know go back
to be more
close closer to the
impact industry let's call it yeah to
find a
more accurate spot for me that will
combine
my values and will keep me at this path
of you know learning about the business
world and
and you know growing my scope of
knowledge and all of that
and then there was the opportunity to
join paulie mytek
which is uh the banking arm of bangkok
poly for startups and
growth companies and uh you know the
high-tech industry eventually i think is
is first of all it's the most amazing
industry because really
there are there is much more than that
just doing business
it's growing the nation is growing
opportunities
it's a it's a sector that you know it
doesn't see um you know background or a
socio-economic
situation or nothing like that it sees
the potential
it's you and this is why you can you can
see so many entrepreneurs that are
coming from you know
surprising backgrounds and all over the
world and specifically
in israel uh and i think it's an amazing
platform for people to change their
their future like we talked before about
unistry right
and in addition there are so many fields
in the high-tech industry that improve
the world so everything in that
makes me feel that i'm in the right spot
because on the one side
i'm doing business you know i'm actually
a banker
you can say that i'm giving services to
the startup
and credit lines and everything and
we're uh leading a
fund-a-fund program investing in vcs
um and uh doing all kinds of other
things that have to do with banking
services
to the high-tech industry but in
addition there is so much
space for innovation and so much
room for you know growing the ecosystem
and giving
values and contributing our aspects
to the startup nation and i i always say
in paulie my tech in every pitch that
every opportunity that i have that i see
that is zionism because eventually you
know this is
uh this is the leadership of the of the
business industry in israel this is the
future of the business industry in
israel
and every everyone says you know that
the coveys show that more than ever when
everyone sank down unfortunately and so
many sectors
in the business uh in the business
industry
went down the high tech went up you know
unbelievably and gave so many
opportunity economic opportunity
um you know uh placement opportunity
uh philanthropy opportunity so many
aspects of
influence that the high-tech industry
has created and is creating right now
and
you know i feel that um first of all i'm
learning so much
and there is so much space for
innovation
in my current uh in my current position
uh and you know the high-tech industry
is growing
and i think we need to be a part of that
and we need to nature that and we need
to do everything in our power as you
know
one of the leading financial
organizations in israel
in order to move this uh train
even faster and to grow this amazing
industry even more than it was before
and uh
and it combines really many of my values
uh
and and you know i feel really happy to
be in this path
today but chef i have to say that you
know
tying it all together all the way from
you know getting that personal
experience saying that
you know around also israel we have you
know all these communities that need the
support and
need this assistance and it's not just
the you know the startup nation and tel
aviv
going into an organization understanding
how to make an impact on a specific
group of people
growing the organization you know
tenfold as the ceo for many years
and and making it international and
making such a huge impact today
every single person i walk on the street
they know unit stream and they
and there's we're just so proud to have
this amazing organization as part of our
dna
it's part of our core culture every year
in a character
the main stage of israel having this
competition
among youth that would have never
necessarily thought about building a
company i think that's just
it's an incredible incredible thing that
i'm completely inspired by
but even even more than that
understanding that continuing to make
this impact and growing this impact
getting that business opportunity and
getting that business experience going
to
a bank which you wouldn't necessarily
think of as a high-tech
entrepreneurial activity but it really
is because it's such a core part of our
ecosystem and
and your role specifically as head of
boiling high tech making that
and making that intersection i think
it's phenomenal and i'm so excited to
see
the incredible impact you're you're
going to continue doing
and and getting inspired by it and and
one day please
let me work for you and but i told them
thank you for coming to the show i
really appreciate it and i need three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh wow and
entrepreneurship definitely
i want to stay leadership and
um
i need another one
yeah and
i want to say um
i want to say giving trying to be the
giving person
i love it i just love that really
important i always say try
you know it's much easier to be on the
giving side than the asking side or the
knitting side so as long as i can be
in the giving side in every aspect of my
life
i really try to you know to do
everything in my power
to actually be at that side and to
justify it
so uh so i want to say given and i hope
i will be able to say that
for the rest of my life thank you for
your time thank you for the inspiration
this is just inspiring and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you very much